any negativity that appears or that that
that somebody else triggers with
negative feelings or negative thoughts
any um
uh any memories appear because they're
ready to be released from our life
that's why they're appearing they're
ready to be free and so i know those
things are inside of us held in our
subconscious mind and when they appear
they're ready to be free so i learned
how to release them really quickly
and
and
it applies to everything
that you
everything negative everything that we
consider negative let's just say that
you're antagonistic and you're bitter
and you're judgmental that's the
person's personality and they get a rush
off of that and all of a sudden they say
no more blaming no more complaining no
more judgment no talking trash but
anyone more gossip yeah i'm going to
stop today yeah goes really well for the
first two hours and the body's going
like hey you're off schedule usually
check emails around 10 o'clock and judge
everybody you're just going to stop that
all of a sudden so
a person sits in their meditation now
listen to this
every time they're sitting in their
meditation they're
in the habit of thinking and feeling
that way
so they're sitting there in meditation
the first 10 minutes goes by and all of
a sudden they start getting frustrated
they start getting impatient ah
they become aware that they're doing it
they don't quit they stop
they return back to the present moment
they relax their body and unfold back
into the moment guess what that's a
victory yeah then they say uh uh the
body wants to get up because it's been
programmed to be busy it wants to move
and you become aware your body wants to
do that
the person who's programmed like this on
autopilot to do the same exact thing
every day in routine they've lost their
free will to a program and their bodies
drag him into that future yeah like i
put myself in uncomfortable positions
and then i see what works and what
doesn't work so an uncomfortable
position is doing an ayahuasca ceremony
an ayahuasca is a plant medicine which
causes a strong physical purge and
generally they call it either the vinus
souls of the vine and death because
it'll
have you confront some very dark you
know challenging issues usually at some
point you know it can be anything really
it's not like a formula but usually
you'll have to confront some very scary
things and some very
challenging things and my very first
ayahuasca experience which taught me a
great lesson in surrender which is one
of the ways that i learned about
surrender
was
it was showing me all of the ways that i
you know i was i could die and i was
dying so like i had snakes that in my
vision state i had snakes that were
coming in they were eating my organs
from the inside out and i could watch
them eat my organs i was like whoa well
that's a little bit scary but i'm okay
with that and i had spiders crawling in
my ears and bursting out of my eyeballs
and going through my brain i was like
that's scary too and then the other one
which was really really i didn't like
this one at all i was sliding down a
tree which was made of spikes spikes on
the bronzers i was sliding down this
tree made of spikes and i was naked
so i was sliding down this three and all
the spikes were just eviscerating all my
genitals and my stomach and i was like
wow that's terrible too
still like a bummer of a day yeah and
i'm still like well you know i'm still
kind of okay with all this but then then
ayahuasca was like
you got cancer and i was like no no no
no no no
no i don't no i don't and i wrestled
with it and i fought i was like no i
don't i'm healthy i'm fine i started
checking my glands and i was like no no
i don't like it's like yeah you do you
do you're gonna die so
when we make that commitment and that
choice it's actually a surrender it's a
surrender it's a state of allowing
because we're really saying i'm gonna
give over all of my stories and belief
systems and agenda and
needs and all the beliefs that we think
that we have to create around ourselves
to feel good enough i'm going to put all
of that aside choose again and allow a
new perspective to come through
so it it can't be another chore it has
to be something that we give over when
we when i say it i mean
personal growth seeing things through
the different lens it has to be a
conscious moment-to-moment choice
and a lot of surrender is required i do
this or i do this i i drink or i don't
um in the chapter i am whole
this is a really interesting chapter
because i think one of the things that
holds us back so much is we become
attached to our behaviors and the yogis
teach us until we are yoked truly to the
true self as humans our behavior is
always going to be unpredictable and
unreliable so what we want to do is we
want to have that you know pull the
shadows out look at the so-called good
and bad and then take the lessons clean
up the mess apologize if we need to but
then let it go so that we're not holding
on to guilt and shame and in the
releasing of it once you've released it
all you'll never feel it again
like there isn't anybody that can
aggravate you in the outside world the
only reason they can aggravate you is
because you have it inside you ready to
be released right which you know very
well so
um
so i just kept releasing and releasing
and what i found was the more i released
the happier i got and so then i would
see things like i had beliefs that
didn't serve me and i would just release
the beliefs that didn't serve me and oh
my gosh then that's beautiful and not
overwhelming not at all you're gonna die
slow painful death
from cancer i was like no no no no and i
started resisting resisting resisting
and i was in so much suffering you know
because when the snakes were coming the
spiders were coming the vine was coming
i was just kind of like yeah okay
you know it's not real and but when i
started to get in the resistance of
having this cancer diagnosis because
it's something you don't want it was
something i was really scared really
scared about because i'd seen my uncle
you know suffer from it i've known that
like it was something that had a really
visceral response that my resistance to
it which is the opposite of surrender
right was causing this massive suffering
and i was purging and i was nauseous
and then finally finally at the end just
out of exasperation i go
okay okay if i do so be it
so be it
and i just took a deep breath and then
ayahuasca felt like it came from the
ground underneath me and embraced me and
held me and it's like you don't have
cancer you're fine you're healthy so
when we make that commitment and that
choice is actually a surrender it's a
surrender it's a state of allowing
because we're really saying i'm going to
give over all of my stories and belief
systems and agenda and
needs and all the beliefs that we think
that we have to create around ourselves
to feel good enough i'm going to put all
of that aside choose again and allow a
new perspective to come through so it it
can't be another chore it has to be
something that we give over when we when
i say it i mean
personal growth seeing things through
the different lens
it has to be a conscious moment to
moment choice
and a lot of surrender is required so
now the body is so strong it's wanting
to move yeah hey come back here you keep
returning it back to the present moment
that's another victory you keep doing
this like training an animal the body is
just going to realize it's no longer the
mind and in that moment there'll be a
liberation of energy that's when the
body finally surrenders right
that's super important because that's a
release of energy and now
that's available energy for the person
to heal with that's available energy now
they can use to design a new future the
body's literally letting go of the fear
letting go of the aggression letting go
of the anger letting go of all those
emotional states and so now what's the
significance of that so now you lowered
the volume to that emotion returned back
to your life just like the sugar uh
donut and coffee you you broke the
addiction you're gonna have no tug there
you are in front of your boss in front
of your ex in front of your greatest
adversary that threw you under the bus
and now you sit in the presence of them
instead of autonomically automatically
physiologically returning into the old
state
you've mastered that emotion you broke
the addiction you'll see a part of you
that you used to be that you no longer
are and you'll no longer have an
aversion you'll just understand that
person's suffering now that's freedom
that means you no longer belong to your
past now you're free you're you belong
to the future and people do that too
it's also surrendering to the positive
stuff like we had a chat about
manifestation right like
there's resistance to even getting
yourself to a positive state where
you're manifesting something positive
sometimes but it's because you have
resistance and that resistance is maybe
you don't think you deserve it maybe you
think it's got to be harder maybe you
think you got to earn it maybe
but if you surrender to that moment and
surrender to the joy of that experience
or maybe it's you're afraid that you
love somebody so much you're afraid of
losing them so you're not surrendering
to how much you love them right you can
surrender to love right like instead of
being in resistance like well i can't
love that much because if they leave me
then i'm going to be that hurt it's
protecting it like it's protecting
yourself it's resisting sure whereas
like the beauty comes in like i [ __ ]
surrender and if
if my heart gets broken
so be it i surrender to that too but i'm
gonna at least love i'm gonna love you
i'm gonna love life i'm gonna love
everything without any resistance
without the fear without any caution
right and just really allow it to be and
just trust that i'll be okay so now the
body is so strong it's wanting to move
hey come back here you keep returning it
back to the present moment that's
another victory you keep doing this like
training an animal the body is just
going to realize it's no longer the mind
and in that moment there'll be a
liberation of energy that's when the
body finally surrenders right
that's super important because that's a
release of energy and now
that's available energy for the person
to heal with that's available energy now
they can use to design a new future the
body's literally letting go of the fear
letting go of the aggression letting go
of the anger letting go of all those
emotional states and so now what's the
significance of that so now you lowered
the volume to that emotion returned back
to your life just like the sugar uh uh
donut and coffee you you broke the
addiction you're gonna have no tug there
you are in front of your boss in front
of your ex in front of your greatest
adversary that threw you under the bus
and now you sit in the presence of them
instead of autonomically automatically
physiologically returning into the old
state
you've mastered that emotion you broke
the addiction you'll see a part of you
that you used to be that you no longer
are and you'll no longer have an
aversion you'll just understand that
person's suffering now that's freedom
that means you no longer belong to your
past now you're free you're you belong
to the future and people do that
it's like what we were talking about
about wanting something so much that the
polar opposite of that is not wanting it
to not happen like you wanted to be
healthy so bad that the other side of it
as you so well explained is you know you
don't want to be you don't want cancer
so much you don't want to be unhealthy
because you want to be healthy so bad
yeah so i had so much fear that i was in
so much resistance and as soon as i
surrendered
you know then then i was rewarded with
that and that you can find that in the
sweat lodge you can find that in in life
in business in the open relationship you
know i had a great mentor in the
in you know as i was going through some
of the challenging parts in the open
relationship and he's like look this is
teaching you to surrender surrender to
these feelings that you're feeling stop
resisting them stop trying to change
them just acknowledge and surrender it
and you'll know it's surrender when it
doesn't feel hard anymore
and i was like oh
it's surrender when it doesn't feel hard
anymore i was like oh okay
you know and and that's that's the point
where i think people think of it like
giving up but it's not it's not giving
up it's actually
having faith
that you're going to be okay that the
universe has your back and that
everything is happening as it should so
it's really an act of faith rather than
an act of defeat